science magazine presents a special
issue each year on the scientific
breakthrough of the year in 2007 its
human genetic variation
in 2001 researchers came out with the
first drafts of the human genome
they were incomplete there were a lot of
places where they didn't know the
sequence and so they kept working on
that by 2003 we had a reference genome
that's where almost all the bases were
in the right place in April of 2003
there will be three dramatic events all
happening at once it historically turns
out to be the 50th anniversary of the
publication of Watson and Crick's famous
paper describing the double helix it is
the month where we will have completed
all of the original goals of a human
genome project including sequencing our
own instruction book the human genome
and it is the month where we will unveil
a plan a bold audacious plan for the
future of where genome research can take
us next that plan included several facts
in addition researchers from around the
world continued to work on understanding
how the human genome differed from that
of other species a very exciting part of
what we've learned from the advances in
DNA sequencing over the last four years
since the human genome the sequence is
how it compares with that of other
organisms more than three dozen
vertebrates have now had their genome
sequenced either to draft or complete
form and that allows by computer a lot
of comparisons to be made and of course
one zeroes in rather quickly on parts of
the genome that appear to be similar
between organisms because those are
probably the ones with the most
important function basically we're
looking at evolutions lab notebook and
figuring out which experiments worked
and that tells you a lot about parts of
the genome that we didn't otherwise
really know were important so less than
a year ago we were really interested in
how our genome compared to our closest
cousins the chimps and the macaque and
by looking at that we could figure out
what it was that made us human but we
have new technologies now and were able
to sequence
or parsley sequence the genomes of
individual people and so we're able to
look at how am i different from you and
to begin to understand what about a
genome makes me me
so DNA variation between people comes in
many forms the simplest form and one
that had a lot of attention and was and
is the single letter differences where
the DNA sequence is the same except some
people have an A at this location and
some people have a T those are called
single nucleotide polymorphisms
abbreviated snips and there are some few
million snips between any two copies of
the human genome more recently in the
last few years there's been attention to
a different class of DNA variation that
we knew existed but hadn't appreciated
was so common and hadn't focused as much
attention on a number of groups around
the world discovered that in addition to
these snips there are places where
people are missing a piece of DNA
altogether it's deleted or there's an
extra copy of a piece of DNA or there's
a repetitive element with some letters
that are repeated over and over again
and different people have different
numbers of repeats all of those can
influence disease as well and as the
catalogs and understanding of DNA
variation improve our power and
completeness of the search for disease
genes also will improve so genome-wide
Association studies show what variants
of a gene are associated with a
particular disease so researchers have
always had a hard time tracking down the
genes underlying disease for the longest
time what they had to use were was large
families and what they would do is track
who which relatives had the disease
which ones didn't and then gradually
narrow in on the gene based on who had
it and who didn't have it with
genome-wide Association studies you
don't need to have relatives you can
look at larger numbers of people of
course broad populations and from there
start figuring out what do peoples with
the symptoms of whatever disease you
have
have in common in their genome and what
they don't the approach of looking at
DNA variation to find the causes of
disease it actually goes back almost a
hundred years to 1913 which is when the
approach was first described by
Sturdivant and it's a very special
approach the geneticists approach
because it doesn't start with guesses or
assumptions about which biological
processes are involved other than saying
the disease runs in families
let the DNA tell me what genes are
responsible so that's what we've been
doing so now that these genome-wide
studies are being done we have specific
connections between genes and disease
between non-coding parts the DNA and
functions and that's the clue we need to
develop a much better understanding of
how our genome leads to disease which is
just a first step to how do we reverse
it or prevent it we read in the press
all the time about the gene that has
just been discovered for cancer or
diabetes or gall stones because we've
had a proliferation of those discoveries
this year but actually we're using a
shorthand there when we say that it
isn't that that's a gene that only the
people who have risk for the disease
carry we all carry the same set of genes
what's really being said is that there's
a variation in that gene that is
conferring a slightly increased risk or
maybe a decreased risk most of these are
not yes/no discoveries they're relative
risks their statistical statements if
you have one of those maybe your risk
goes up by twenty or thirty percent but
you might still not get the condition
but the good news is that after many
years decades in fact of being
frustrated about our ability to find
those variations that are responsible
for common disease risk they are turning
up all over the place and they're really
transforming our understanding of those
diseases
for the last 12 months the big story has
been finally the tools have arrived to
allow us to discover the genetic
variations that predict risk of common
diseases the diseases that fill up our
hospitals and our clinics with people
who have chronic illnesses for which we
have inadequate treatments I'm talking
about diabetes the common cancers mental
illness asthma gallstones atrial
fibrillation Crohn's disease rheumatoid
arthritis all of those conditions where
in just the last few months we have
discovered very significant genetic
contributors to risk each one of those
gives us a wholly new idea about what
this disease is all about and a whole
bunch of follow-on projects can get
going immediately to try to figure out
how to prevent the disease or to cure it
and people who've developed it so we
really have crossed the bridge into new
territory in terms of understanding the
most common most complex conditions and
so it's been a long effort by many many
groups around the world to get in a
position to do these studies and we
honestly didn't know the answer until
the last year and in fact if you look at
a diagram that reports the rate of
discovery of contributors to common
human diseases as they exist in the
clinic from let's say the years 2000 to
2004 so the rate of discovery is across
a wide right diseases maybe one new
discovery per year maybe two that was
actually faster than in the previous
decade when you could go a decade
without any new contributors to common
diseases being found through this
genetic approach and in the last year in
2007 there probably 75 bona fide
reproducible discoveries across a wide
variety of diseases of novel
contributors to genetic to common
diseases through this genetic approach
our technology is advancing very quickly
already it's possible on the basis of a
couple of companies that are marketing
directly to consumers for people to have
their DNA tested in hundreds of
thousands of places if they're willing
to cough up a thousand dollars or so to
get that done the question is exactly
how would you use that information so
the more we solve these mysteries the
more we learn about what our DNA
actually contains the more issues that
will arise there's questions about
privacy and there's also questions about
discrimination based on our DNA and of
course since people have a right to know
their DNA information that's a fine
thing but the question of how often this
will improve their health and how often
this will cause unnecessary anxiety and
whether or not we're really doing more
harm than good
that will be something for society to
watch quite a bit because there's not
just the potential for improved
lifestyle and Prevention which is a
wonderful thing there's of course the
risk of unnecessary anxiety and concern
there's actually the risk that people
will begin to think about using this in
selecting mates or in reproductive
choices which might be something that
people have different opinions on how
desirable that is we need to have a lot
of discussion in society about what's
the right use of this information what's
the right way to do it in the medical
context what's the rights of individuals
to get that information and to profit
from that information and I think that
if we have that discussion we'll
probably I believe in the wisdom of
people I'm sure we'll come to good
answers
science is published by triple-a s the
science Society